thank you everyone
for joining the session on accelerating
application development with anthos
uh this is a rough agenda for today
we'll have a quick introduction
we'll talk about challenges of
application delivery today we'll talk
about
application development with anthos and
then we will get into
how our enterprises can migrate from pcs
using kf and anthos quick introduction
about
myself my name is balaji raja i've been
at google cloud since 2016.
uh i'm a solutions manager with the
application modernization team
first let's talk about uh the challenges
of application delivery today uh we have
been talking to customers
about the challenges what they are
facing and
they have talked us to us about their
business objectives as well as
their technology objectives uh as far as
their business objectives go
most enterprises are looking to
accelerate time to market
for new capabilities and features uh and
especially in the current climate costs
are on top of their minds
so they're looking to reduce costs as
well uh
how that translates into technology
objectives is they're trying to
drive speed and agility using automation
uh they are trying to improve developer
efficiency
uh through a self-service uh they want
to have
a unified operating models across
on-prem
and hybrid or multi-clouds because most
organizations have started adopting
public clouds and
security is also top of mind for most
folks so they want to ensure whatever
solution they choose
has the best in class security and
compliance
but if you look at those points
traditional software development
and testing and deployment has not
really
kept up with those demands let's see
look at some of the reasons why it has
not
traditional enterprise software
development was developed
for the on-prem work so it has several
limitations when it comes to addressing
most modern application delivery models
traditional enterprise software
development relies on
imperative thinking where things are
much more specifically defined
whereas more modern application
development relies on
a declarative approach previously in
enterprises
applications once they're developed they
go through a security evaluation process
and that is how they get approved for
deployment and that usually comes
towards the
end of the software development life
cycle what that means is it becomes a
choice between fixing the security
issues
and going into production enterprises
are looking to change that and
incorporate security into every phase of
their software development life cycle
increasingly companies are also starting
to adopt open source software
and that is causing them to rethink how
they
test as well as deploy software
the typical governance models which i in
use within organizations
were created for the on-premise work and
those have not really kept up with the
kind of
rapid deployments which you see in
companies who have adopted public cloud
and those also need to change
devops research and assessment is an
organization which
does a research on these topics and this
is a company which
google acquired a little while ago
they published a report in 2019 after
talking to a lot of enterprises about
the state of
uh devops in those respective
organizations and they had some key
findings
the first one was delivering software
quickly reliably
and safely is at the heart of technology
transformation and it really affects the
organization performance
most companies come from the on-prem
world and they
bring that approach to public cloud as
well
and that is not conducive to optimum
performance
so how you implement your cloud
infrastructure really matters
the other one is the change approval
process which are prevalent in
enterprises and those can be pretty
antiquated which uh
goes through many uh hoops uh before you
can get approved to
deploy software and uh that has to be
reduced so that it can you can cater to
the modern
development approaches which are
prevalent today
so when the dora team looked at the
organizations and tried to evaluate them
they evaluated them on
four key parameter meters the first one
is the lead time
required for deployment uh the second
one is how
often can you deploy the third one
is how quickly you can recover uh and
change in case of a failure
and the last one was what is the time
required to restore
in case of a issue
so they broke these metrics into uh
different categories and based on these
parameters they classified organizations
into elite high medium and low and if
you look at the elite
organizations they uh they have
on-demand deployments where they can do
multiple deployments per day
and they have a change failure rate of
less than 15
and when you come to the low performing
organizations they deploy maybe once a
month or in the worst case scenario once
every six months
and they have change failure rates which
are really bad
but if you look at the majority of the
organizations they fall in the middle
around 67 percent of organizations they
evaluated
fall in the high or medium category but
all these organizations have a desire to
shift left and become more elite in
their performance
so this is where developing with anthos
comes in because anthos was
built from the ground up uh to cater to
these kind of requirements
so athos was a result of 15 years of
google's innovation in this area
right from 2003 when google engineers
created borg
which again became open sourced as
kubernetes all the way up to 2019
when anthos was released
so let's see how antos enables cloud
native development
today the first aspect which a lot of
our customers are looking at
is a security uh they want separation of
duties so that the developers
and the activities they do are separated
from the activities which the operators
and deployment folks do
uh they want effective vulnerability
management and being able to
have effective access controls um they
want
uh to be able to define their
infrastructure both
uh as code uh as well as the application
platform
it allows them to automate the
activities which they do
so that it is better auditable and it
can be controlled better as well
effective deployment of applications
mean that they are
containerized so that they can be
isolated from other applications
and they are extensible and transparent
and most organizations are concerned
about
being locked into a particular vendor so
it has to be open standards based and
antho satisfies all these criteria
so let's look at how hand those enables
uh elite devops performance
uh today it reduces the developer
a platform because it it shields the
developers from knowing the details of
the platform so that they can
focus on value-add activities it
established governance and separation of
roles across application life cycle
and organizations are able to centrally
control
uh configuration and policies across
applications and themes
uh it also allows them to leverage
existing investments and
skill sets because uh anthos is based on
kubernetes and it can run on any
cloud platform and it also provides them
the flexibility to build test and run
their applications
wherever they choose so these are a
couple of our customers who have
uh used anthos to increase their devops
performance
uh case compressor is a one of the
leading manufacturers or compressors in
the world
they use anthers to modernize existing
applications on their
uh current infrastructure uh hsbc used
it slightly differently they used uh
anthos to accelerate their software
velocity in a hybrid demand
next let's look at how uh
you can modernize and migrate your cloud
foundry applications
uh using anthos and kf this applies to
both uh pivotal cloud foundry
applications as well as the open source
cloud foundry applications
so when we spoke to uh pcf customers
this is where some of the insights we
had
pcf came into popularity a few years ago
and it gained a
large mind share with customers
predominantly because
developers really love the opinionated
workflow
developers love the fact that they can
they can build compile their app
build it can turn it into a image and
deploy it
in in a short while through a simple
command
like cf push but at the same time
operators have been struggling with
managing cloud foundry workloads
so for instance bosch which forms the
underlying technology
of cloud foundry is not as flexible or
as general purpose as
a platform like kubernetes and
operators are increasingly getting used
to using more declarative
approaches to application deployment and
they want that same out of all of their
platforms and most organizations have
started to adopt kubernetes
so now uh cloud foundry becomes yet
another platform to
maintain so they're maintaining a cloud
foundry platform as well as a kubernetes
platform
and especially if you're using uh
pivotal's cloud foundry
uh it means that you are paying a lot in
licensing cost or subscription cost
uh the model of pivotal is based on
application instances so
every time you deploy a new application
instance you have to pay
a subscription cost to pivotal so that
essentially
discourages architectures like
using microservices because that is
predicated on deploying
multiple instances of an application to
scale up and so on
so given that uh people are looking for
better ways to
uh do their application development so
we spoke
to our people from different parts of
the organizations the two personas we
focused on was developers and operators
and we focused on what are the things
which are important to them
so for the developer they really want an
opinionated workflow where they don't
have to worry about the underpinnings of
the platform
they want to compile build and deploy
images easily
they also want to be platform agnostic
so that when the
company decides to move from one
platform to the other they do not have
to come back and change something
they also want the option to move to a
zero ops mod
on the operator side of the house they
really want declarative platform
management
uh organizations which have moved to uh
public cloud
have uh used things like terraform to
automate
and uh make it more declarative to
create the infrastructure
so they want that same out of their
application platforms as well
they want to be able to apply common
policies across enterprise so that they
can standardize
on how they operate their platforms uh
they want uh
higher visibility into microservices
because enterprises are increasingly
adopting microservices
and it is vital to them to understand
the information behind those
and probably most importantly most as
most organizations are starting to
adopt public cloud they are looking for
ways to
uh limit their operational cost and that
can only happen if you can have a
unified control plane
across on-prem as well as public cloud
so this is where kf comes in kf was
developed uh
by google from the ground up so what it
allows the developers to
do is uh use kf in the same manner they
would use
uh cf commands or the cloud foundry
commands uh they can issue a kf command
which will interact with all the
underlying components of anthos
to provide the same experience which the
developers would have
when they use a cloud foundry uh
operators on the other hand can
use all the declarative approaches
provided by crypto and all the
kubernetes tools
to manage the platform
so what is care so the kf is meant to
uh provide developers the cloud foundry
experience while empowering
operators to adopt declarative practices
we allow uh organizations to move their
cloud foundry applications to anthos
without causing any disruption to their
developers
kf is built by google uh from the ground
up natively on kubernetes
uh we do not use any of the cloud
foundry components uh so that means that
the
organizations no longer have to pay the
subscription or licensing cost
behind cloud foundry say implementation
like for pivotal
and administrators can operate the
platform
using kubect and uh below are listed
some of the commands which are supported
as part of cf
so when we built a kf
we actually brought the best of pcf to
anthos
we ensure we have provide a cf-like
developer workflow
we wanted to make sure that we are
building it on natively on top of
kubernetes so that we remove any of the
dependencies from cloud foundry
uh build packs are a common way uh how
enterprises standardize how their
images are built and deployed so it is
very important to
organizations which use cloud foundry
that we provide support for buildbacks
and that is available as part of kf and
we looked at the commonly used commands
from enterprises
and we added support for 40 plus
commands and we also added support for
service brokers
and service brokers are the mechanisms
which cf use
cf applications use to communicate with
external resources
uh technical support of kfo kf is
provided through all google cloud
support channels
there is no additional cost to using kf
kf support is included as part of your
antho subscription
it is supported both on prem as well as
on gcp and other public clouds
and standard google cloud application
policies apply
look at a migration uh from pcf
uh to anthos so on the left-hand side in
phase one you see
the up the enterprise uh status as of
today
right where they have cf applications as
well as kubernetes
application and their platform team is
maintaining two different platforms one
is cloud foundry
another is probably a container platform
like kubernetes
so that means that the operational
overhead is high
for the organization in phase two when
they start adopting antos and kf
now they have a single platform to
maintain which is anthos
the operators running a cf application
can use kf and the folks running
kubernetes applications can
deploy their applications on a cloud run
rgk
or google kubernetes engine as the
organization develops a comfort level
with anthos and gke
and cloud run they can slowly start
migrating their cloud foundry
applications
from using kf to running natively on
cloud run or gke and we do not mandate
that
organizations do that within a certain
amount of time they can continue to use
kf until
their level reach the level of comfort
where they can migrate their
applications over
and in phase four uh you see the
enterprise has completely moved over
from uh cloud foundry applications to
kubernetes application
and they're using cloud ram and gke
let's look uh now through the various uh
phases of a pcf migration
so there are multiple parts where you
can migrate
from pcf to others and we provide
different pathways for it
for enterprises no enterprises are built
the same and everybody has their own
challenges so we acknowledge it
so certain enterprises feel very
comfortable moving uh straight away from
pcf uh to uh something like cloudrun or
gke
uh either on anthos on-prem or on
gcp which is managed by google but other
organizations have their uh challenges
because migrating
hundreds of apps built on cloud foundry
it's not that simple
uh so they can migrate to anthones and
use kf
uh which will effectively simplify the
operation because they have only one
platform to manage
and continue on on that pathway of
running the cloud foundry applications
until they feel comfortable moving to
cloud.gke
uh the first phase of moving your cloud
foundry application
from cloud foundry to anthos is running
an assessment
so as part of the kf tool we provide an
assessment capability
uh you can run the kf tool against your
cloud foundry application
and it will actually tell you what if it
is a good fit for
the kf platform so in the next slide you
actually
see a sample report which is generated
by the kf2
and on the right hand side it's actually
showing whether
the migration assessment has passed or
not the next stage of using kf to
migrate your applications is now
uh to deploy those applications yeah and
you can do that through
the simple cli of kf and kf push
and you can migrate your existing
applications to anthos
uh the screen shows an example of
deploying
one of the very popular applications
which are used to
demonstrate the capabilities of cloud
foundry it's called spring music and
in this case we are deploying that
application
using kf and the developer experience
will be
pretty much uh similar uh to what they
will see with cloud foundry
once you have deployed the application
now you get to the portion where you're
operating it
uh so the developers can use the various
command line uh
arguments which are required uh which
are available to operate the
applications which they move from pcf to
kf
and operators can use the kf
installation
with the gke and anthony's tools to
manage the deployments
so here you see examples of some of the
kf commands developers can use
to look at their applications they can
use kf scale to scale out their
applications they can use kf logs
to look at the logs of generated by
their application
and operators can use
the various uis which are available to
manage gke
and cloud run to actually see what the
status of our application is
it provides them a single pane of glass
for managing
both their configuration and policies
both on-prem and
in the cloud so they can look at their
configuration and policies
as well as get deep visibility into your
applications through services and
networking
and your call to action today is please
review the resources which are linked as
part of the session
if you are interested in learning more
about our pcf migration strategy
please reach out to your account team
and please talk to us
about how we can kickstart a pilot for
migrating from pcf to andros
with that i wrap up my presentation
thank you for joining me today